[Music]
um let's go into the footwork we started
this last time okay U I use you Virginia
in the in this in the video our footwork
is
just horrendous in The Gua okay except
for those that can get it
okay
um there's some saying attributed to O
Sensei like the stable
stance is indicative of the stable mind
or the centered stance is indicative of
the center of mind it's hard to know
what he meant or if he even said it but
there is something to the fact
that
um the mind
the reconciled mind does
manifest in the natural body mechanics
that are indicative of what is the right
body mechanics okay because what is
natural is what is
right and what is right is what is
natural they go
together but in that there is the notion
that aside from my mind that I'm
matching or corresponding
whatever footwork I adopt for the
environment incident what what do I have
going on what am I trying to do you
don't want to have a style of
moving you want to have this naturalness
of moving okay that matches how you're
moving where your weight is ETC to the
environment incident that you're
addressing so for example I don't stand
in the in the iido
s unless I have an environment and an
incident that calls for that but don't
adopt it right from the beginning
doesn't work so if you're
up and we're sparring this would be the
worst thing for me to do
okay um it's not very mobile right
you're just going to be able to close
and get angles on me very very
quickly um it's wrong it's wrong not
because it's iido it's wrong because in
that
situation it's in the wrong place at the
wrong time so for example what is that
situation well that situation is not
calling
for
stability of a bracing angle on this
line you see so if you just slightly get
offline then I don't don't have that
stability would just push you see I
don't have that
stability and so if you get in that
stance again he's very strong right
here so it seems cool but as I'm coming
in I'll change angle very quickly very
subtly and just I don't know anything
but to push and it takes away the
practicality of that stance it's in the
wrong place at the wrong time
okay of course some stances are so
specialized that there's very few times
that they will be natural and therefore
right therefore correspond to an
environment incident it's just like that
environment incident almost never comes
up okay and that's one of that's an
additional problem to the
k um so
we have to understand yet my footwork
has to correspond to what's actually
going on what's the environment incident
has to do
that but are there any
universal elements or aspects to my
footwork yes there there are okay and
that's midfoot vectran I'm going to try
to midfoot
Vector um I'm going to have my line of
gravity inside my b of
support um I'm going to
have um a prioritization of Mobility
things like that okay so for example if
we go into that sparring
thing I don't want my weight on my heel
on the front foot my weight is on that
is on that midfoot so here's here's
weight on my heel do you see I shift
weight onto that onto that midfoot in
order to get there I'm going to have to
bend my knees drop my
Center then on the other foot I'm on the
I have my heel up but I'm still on the
midfoot I'm not on my toes the heel is
up but I'm still here and so now I can
move around so he tries to change that
angle again and I can
move because in that time incident you
haven't committed you haven't done
anything I don't know what you're doing
I don't know where your openings are yet
I haven't chosen my offense
so I want to prioritize the kind of
neutrality the kind of Maximum potential
so I adopt that stance that stance is
correct this stance is not correct
okay so yes it has to match the
environment incident and yes there are
Universal kind of
principles uh that I do I will always
have to buy by as I'm matching my
footwork to the environment incident
okay so let's go into the drill we were
doing and let's say I think we're doing
from
De and he's got his spinal
displacement and of course I don't want
to go like
this this isn't going to cut it
but at the same time I don't want to go
here because I'm overc committed to one
angle when there's still lots of angles
that he could
take so we use the internals he's
pressing and I can hold my ground here
pretty much in
50/50 the only difference is I didn't
put that heel
up in the phasing stance where there was
more potential of what it all could be
so I'm going to prioritize
Mobility
but it's pretty much the same
stance
okay it doesn't mean you can't do it
with your heel up you can you can you
can it's still the
midfoot but I know I'm not moving I'm
not shuffling so it doesn't give me
anything let me put the heel
down when it comes to how much pressure
you have It's a combination of things
again specific to the environment
incident so for
example if I can internalize a lot I can
stay more still longer meaning more in
place and move in
but if he got to go slow so I can talk
if he starts to break my midfoot V
Journey before I got here and I lost
my
position positional
organization I can always take whatever
value I have on on midfoot vectory and
take some pressure off of him by
changing
angles and that's where I now start to
bring not just the stance but my foot
work so I'm here and I don't have to go
like this until I figure something
out I'll
feel the compromisation and before it
takes over I move to take pressure off
of him pressure
value from him
okay and that way my
footwork is
very
simple this is very
complicated doesn't
work this is very
simple to that I can add my
tabaki so right here the pressure that I
felt that wanted me to
step I can take pressure off to with my
pattern so the pressure that I'm feeling
that led me to be compromised there that
wanted me to
step you can change with your hand
work by nonc contesting at the hand work
so I'm doing all of these
things as I need to all of them as I
need to or as I want to if you're still
getting
there but my feet
are
stop they don't
wiggle step or
anything more than they have to they're
just
stuck
stuck the only time and the only way
they're going to
wiggle or you're going to get in
weird positional
organizations is because because you can
test it that's the only reason I got
here and I'm starting to lean well I'm
getting pinned if you pay attention I'm
getting pinned before I got here I
should have just taken some pressure
value from him or move
myself or if I get
displaced it's cuz I'm not in the right
place at the right time I'm not matching
the incident the environment incident
okay
so we do our
drill keep your feet
still don't try to be all powerful we
don't do that we're we're not
here uh like we're tii people and I
don't move my
feet we reconcile both internal and
external and you move
accordingly what's accordingly so that I
move naturally so that I move correctly
so that I'm in
[Music]
harmony with my environment incident I
can mix any of those factors however I
need to give you
that all right let's try the energy any
questions yes
it feels
like in your reps that there is a direct
one to one connection to my input and
the timing of your foot that's moving to
maintain that X
and when I'm training with these guys I
feel like that happens before the
actual balls push before before the
energy kind
of it is before so they're not y y
clashing but it feels like it's ahead of
me and therefore there's a
delay on the projection point where
yours feels like this I move your foot
foot ground and that immediately sends
me pop out but it feels like I get
sucked in yeah the longer there okay so
this so if I'm and correct me if I'm not
understanding this your question so uh
when when he pushes on
me as he gets deeper into the the
pressure then he goes right away into
the projection as as opposed
to this okay so what what so what is
what's let me give words to the second
one the second one is this is how I
understand it you have an external
deviation
and then you press the ground Vector
into their Center so again I I'm moving
over here and then I push okay but as
he's going you already have the the
center so you can move it this way you
see you can move it this way and you can
put it on whatever foot you want so
let's say I want to Bounce It Off the
front foot you see so he's hitting the
front foot when he does that or or he'll
hit my left foot when when I project
that okay and so one of the ways you can
tell aside from feeling it is the extra
movement you see I had to shift and my
hands had
to move okay um and well okay what is
that well that's about from the moment
of contact wherever he touches you you
already are in his Center what what's
happening now is I'm not in his Center
not in his Center till I push into him
okay and that is I think obviously
that's something different and
obviously you won't really have
kazushi that's why I say the center
seizure is what I do at the beginning is
the seed of kazushi so
um what happens when you do an external
kazushi in real life is the person just
adjusts to it and now you're just you go
back and forth and if they're stronger
faster if they have initiative you're
never going to get kazushi okay um so
the difference is Center seizure at
contact versus external deviation and
then a projection through the center
okay um while it's not correct and it's
not right I do think it's a stepping
stone okay because
even here we might see like our brand
brand new people okay so our brand new
people they're going to do the external
deviation
right but once they do the external
deviation they like miss his Center
you see so even even if I'm in here and
you're like at least you know where the
center is you can feel the center I
think it is a step but like all steps
leading to where we want to
go
they're there snakes in the
tree you see they're
they're they're there to entice you away
from where you need to be
okay um and you have to not trust them
uh don't stay there don't don't listen
to that serpent whisper okay you just
keep working on with the pointers that
the teacher giving okay on the person
[Music]
who stays there Falls pray to the
serpent is the person who didn't
listen to what the teacher said
okay so always come back to the
mechanics and just you're right in
pointing out that is something different
yes it is something different and
everyone here should be working to move
past that okay but it it is a step your
job is to make it a step and not the end
product any other questions or followup
to
that okay
so if we're now going to do do a
technique and not just a simple
projection nothing changes at all in
what I said so I still feel what he's
doing I still
see his
body and I move and shift and time and
change my handworth according to all
those rules does that make sense okay so
I don't I'm not going to
do anything weird with my feet I'm not
going to do this
[Music]
stuff okay my feet
are
moving
exactly the
[Music]
okay not a million baby
steps not wiggly wiggly not pushing off
I can
mix stance work
internalization foot workor hand work to
make sure I keep my positional
organization and keep my naturalness to
the environment
incident let's
try he said at the
beginning that I have to be in sync with
the with the environment incident
because if if I
don't I'm going to eventually
contest and then that's where all this
stuff starts overriding and that's where
you have to have more internal skills
and uh more strength and all kinds of
like that
okay how do I get out of syn with the
environment
incident second question is how do I get
ins synct with the environment incident
okay so we like to think as
moderns that in this drill I'm going to
take advantage that he
has okay and now I'm going to do my
technique you can see he's already kind
of going into
that and that's kind of what
happens that
we we start to believe that this works
because myuk
is going to try to figure out what I'm
doing okay but what I like to do is uh
let's say he does that again so he's
he's moving himself over there CU as I
go faster which way did you
go you see he went to the other side but
somehow he got over there somehow he
goes over there with that step you see
so that's his agency so what I do in the
Gaza is I did this and my UK counter
that's what that is my UK counter so I
take him where he doesn't want to go
wherever I feel that he wants to go I
don't take him where he wants to go does
that make
sense and what the takeaway here is your
UK
is going like did I know that he was
going to walk that foot over there you
say I'll be the UK okay and this is the
tenaga set up you see and there's no way
from here I can know that you're going
to step with your lead foot to the right
there's no way from here I could know
there's no way from here do you see do
you see that so you keep going and I
took that keep going I take that step
that's what
turn but he took that step and there's
no way I could know in Gaza that you're
going to do that so my point is that the
UK is always going to do something
weird when weird here
means they just saw agency in it okay
that's just what happened um in all kind
of ways and then now I can't match it
the way that I thought I could in other
words I thought I that he would
recognize this and I could go here and I
could go like that can you see but you
can't because sometimes he's coming in
straight like this sometimes for some
reason he took that step sometimes he's
at an angle do you see one hand has this
PR pressure one hand has that pressure
and as a result the environment incident
is constantly in flux do do you see it's
constantly influx to the degree that sh
or ten that you were planning is could
be now out of whack with the environment
incident okay so for example you do that
same step and I'm oh what the hell do
you
see it's not right I'm forcing the
technique
okay this doesn't work it just doesn't
work but more than that it's not to you
wasn't
okay what you have to do instead in
order to be and let's say in harmony
with the environment incident is not be
that's the
problem when you
are following
desires intentions
fears you're going to
eventually be out of sync with what this
person is doing under those kind of
training parameters and as a result so
we'll do let's say I go I'm telling
myself my intention my desire is to do
sh or and my fear is that you're so big
and heavy that anything else like on
your arms is not going to work do you
see and but you take that step
you see and I'm trying to do this
technique now and now I have to do
something that isn't real and I force it
and technique stopped and the D get
stopped and my foot work got all weird
as a result of that okay what I do
instead is he push he pushed I have this
weird say there okay I have uh a inward
pressure here there's a there's an
actual inward pressure there do you see
this one not so much it's a little in
but not so much so I feel that and I
don't try to go how do I get from there
to tenin I don't do that the pressure
that I feel there well let me just have
this hand I don't go against it I don't
go against it I'm not going to go here
I'm not going to go there do you see
I'll yield to
it then he has the other
[Music]
hand you see and now maybe I find the sh
the tenin Naga over
here you
see in other words you have to not have
a desire not have an intention not have
a fear and just be with what he's doing
so what is what am I doing he moved the
hand you moved the hand I know for
example if this hand gets all the way to
this Y Line it's wrong you see how
smashed I
am so I know I could go to the wui line
and as it starts to go pass I have to
rotate it's telling me what my footwork
is do you
see and if I can't move like I can't
move due to what's happening right
there's a lot of pressure still if you
pay attention it's coming back this way
do you see and if I take a step forward
stay where you are you'll feel the
increase y I'm just going to walk that
way
keep keep your motion going you see it
increase you see it's increase at the
pump you see that and if I go this way
that's weird footwork that's a weird
footwork so because he is still now
turning he's doing that I'm not doing
that I'm not pulling him in he's leaning
in on me you see that's why this hand
goes down and I go to the outside of it
and the footwork now has to
follow the
hand don't don't judge yourself CU it's
Gaza okay so his pressure initially
brought my hand that way he's doing this
iido thing so for those who don't know
what I'm talking about let's switch
gos okay he
is going this way
normal
people go go this way you see that
difference there's nothing there yes you
see
that you decided to go this
way so he pushed it that way I let it go
that way we're at gon let's do that
first okay why can't I go to to uh to
jodon
right cuz he's got some downward on it
this downward and inwardness so I'm not
going to try to lift that I let him turn
it I'm in gon before it gets to here I
have to turn he's driving in that way
I'm not pulling it he's doing that now I
know I can't go there cuz I'm going to
break that rule I know I can't step
there that's a weird
footwork and I know I can't go that way
because he's pushing me that way so
that's where my footwork follows my
hand and I don't have to wiggle my feet
okay he's deciding what I'm
doing if you pick the technique if you
desire the technique if you desire
something not to
happen if your fears are getting
you you won't be able to be in harmony
with the environment incident okay
then your footwork will be
likewise if you're strong enough
like you
are your Technique looks something like
this you see you're
like and it's
not it's not
that it's just my hand wve
okay
try all right so do you
think that that you're not going to have
desires fears and
intentions one
day do you understand you know you
that's your ego tripartite mind that's
part of you okay so what is it that
allows
me to harmonize with this environment
incident I am going to have those things
that don't allow me to what is the skill
that I
use to allow me to harmonize with the
environment
incid skill of release the skill of
release okay so you're going to
feel like you feel the pressure do you
see you're going to feel the desire the
fear the
intention and you're going to do the
skill of
release the same their
energy you're going to bring
down as you bring that energy down that
ego tripartite mind is going to drop you
let that happen as you let that happen
it will move your body where it needs to
be it it can the only way it won't move
where it needs to
be is because you got snapped out of the
god
M do you see the energy came up your
body the Mind came up your body the Chi
came up your body and now you have to
force these things
okay you want to do Gaza like you you
can't make this a thing a
footwork per se but the footwork can be
a window into what is your state of mind
cultivation okay but you can't go I go
to midfoot Victor I'm going to move my
inward outward SP rals no because this
is not an architectural thing this is a
mind thing here mind not in the Western
Psych psychological sense but in
the Buddhist spiritual sense okay this
is a mind thing you have to be able to
release the ego triarte mind has to be
able to drop
then you then and only then can you be
in true harmony with the environment
incident okay that's the whole point of
Gaza training that is what you're trying
to do it's the same stress adaptation
model the UK is going to stress you
means they're going to
trigger desire fear and
tension right and then in that under
that stress you have to deconstruct the
ego tripartite Minds through the skill
of release then you will move
harmoniously with the okay right there
and then not predicting the technique
out right I don't you know I think I
think it's hard for
the for the
ferite trying to understand this because
they've been so convinced of what guaza
is where they just pick a ahead of time
but when I look at their technique it's
always full ATT tension there's always
these weird things these weird pressures
on the feet the toes curl up little baby
steps little hesitations in movement
it's not smooth the energy is not
flowing right the UK is not moving there
are telltale signs if you pay attention
uh the UK is throwing themselves all
kinds of stuff like that um it is
visible
I think if you slow it down maybe and
you really concentrate on it you can see
it anyone can see it but when you feel
the nag who doesn't have a technique in
mind it's radically different and as you
said it's very energy draining it's
extremely energy draining as UK because
you now as UK have no idea where you're
going because the NGA has no idea where
you're going you can't tell what you're
supposed to do or not you're not
supposed to do okay and anything
you try to do ends up being used against
you right because you didn't calculate
what you did into what's going to happen
but the release
nugget is having it calculated in you
see so lot and the reason why this
becomes difficult is a lot of the a lot
of the time those little agencies that
the ukit takes are self-preservation
energies control seeking uh uh attempts
and the release nogget is is going to
move in a way that to you it just like
this I this is actually making it worse
for me you as the UK experience in that
way and that generates more fear and
that generates more exhaustion as you're
bringing more tension into your body and
as you bring more tension into your body
that makes you more throwable for the
release s get not less mobile and things
like that and just start spotting Auto
control okay but that is what we're
doing any closing questions